dan asked what's your process for
vetting clients specifically a
vaynermedia Dan answer number one do you
have enough money Dan answer number two
what I'm really looking for to not make
a joke and you know it's just putting me
in a better mood guys I gotta be honest
with you I forgot that that's what Wine
Library TV did for me on these Mondays
where I want to annihilate people's
souls putting on a show with my
community does help my field I need a
lot of comments on this episode by the
way I need comments in there I need I
need comments anyway you know the the
things we're looking out for is are they
creative the number one thing I'm scared
of is we have a ton of creativity and we
can do real work but if people want to
follow a very strict process of how
they've always done it versus how we're
supposed to do it I'm petrified in that
so really there's no way to do it
because everybody says they want to be
innovative and due to the new thing and
invest in the future and then you get
into practicality and the first thing
that's cut is the future which is why so
many people lose so everybody's into
defense versus offense when times get
tough for me when times get tough you go
harder not aim anyway so I'm trying to
sniff out if people have the stomach to
be innovative and do things differently
to take some risks but be practical but
have a little more patience for that
practicality and that ROI to present
itself